this is going to sound really strange
but it appears that Donald Trump doesn't
know the difference between life
insurance and health insurance and
mistakenly believes that sometimes
health insurance costs only $1 a month
this isn't the most shocking part of
that interview that Trump gave last week
to the New York Times but I realized
when I was checking out transcripts of
the entire thing Trump doesn't seem to
know the difference between health
insurance which covers medical services
and life insurance which pays
beneficiaries when you die here's a
quote from Donald Trump from this
interview and it is bizarre Trump said
quote so pre-existing conditions are a
tough deal because you're basically
saying from the moment the insurance
you're 21 years old you start working
and you're paying $12 a year for
insurance and by the time you're 70 you
get a nice plan here's something where
you walk up and say I want my insurance
it's a very tough deal but it is
something that we're doing a good job of
okay so it's almost completely
unintelligible but there's a couple
things in there that we can comment on
Trump talks about $12 a year for
insurance or $1 a month it seems he's
talking about term life insurance okay
sometimes when you watch TV you'll see
these commercials offering term life
insurance for $1 a month or some really
cheap amount and in fact Gerber
advertises for life insurance for babies
on Fox News for really really cheap so
maybe Trump actually got this idea from
Fox News didn't realize what life
insurance isn't the same thing as health
insurance what Trump is referring to
they're saying by the time you're 70 you
get a nice plan
here's something where you walk up and
say I want my insurance that refers to a
product called whole life insurance
which has what's called a cash value
that cash value accrues over time and
eventually if you're in a whole life
plan for a very long time decades
typically you can cash in the policy for
quite a bit of money relative to what
you are originally paid in but also
whole life insurance isn't the type that
costs a dollar a month the dollar a
month stuff is term life insurance but
the bigger picture is term life
insurance
whole life insurance neither is health
insurance which is what Donald Trump
seems to be confused about there isn't
health insurance for $1 a month in the
market the Kaiser Family Foundation
estimates that the average American
yearly premium for a sort of
middle-of-the-road individual plan
offered through the Obamacare exchanges
in 2016 was about 4500 dollars per year
or just under $400 a month this is red
alert level and competence Pat the
person who ran a presidential campaign
claiming that he would fix healthcare
for the entire country doesn't realize
the difference between term life
insurance he sees advertised on TV and
health insurance I guess you do have to
give him a pass though because Donald
Trump just recently found out that
health care is a complicated issue it
just it doesn't make too much sense to
me how could you even if you're in your
billionaire bubble think that health
care could cost someone only $12 a year
when it's the top reason for
bankruptcies in the United States when
we're having such a vigorous debate over
this and when people are going to
needlessly die if the ACA was repealed
there's just no way what occurred to me
was if you're trump and you're this
billionaire right and you've been eating
out of a silver spoon your entire life
maybe for you you don't even understand
like maybe $12 a year and 4,500 dollars
a year to Trump are basically the same
thing like for him it's like oh yeah
people are up in arms because it's a lot
of money for them and maybe the Trump
hearing that something is $12 a year
sounds like not very much and hearing
that something is $4,500 a year also
doesn't sound like very much and he just
genuinely has no idea what this stuff
costs still though I think you
understand that if the minimum wage is
$7.25 in the entire country then people
can afford health insurance for the
entire year over just a couple hours of
work I know it's ridiculous if you were
Trump and you thought people could get
health insurance for $1 a month
you'd probably be wondering why this
entire debate is even such a big debate
which might explain why he doesn't seem
to care about it and it hasn't happened
and he just seems to offhandedly say oh
we'll just do this or we'll do that it
doesn't really matter in the end
it makes me think that Donald Trump was
not involved in the entire
our healthcare process as he claimed
yeah I think that that is suspect to say
that he's been involved all the way when
he came how do you how are you involved
in the creation of something like the
American Health Care Act to whatever
degree he was involved and even if it
was just meetings with Senators and
members of the House of Representatives
and end up thinking that you might be
able to get health care for 12 bucks a
year I mean it just does not compute to
me and what we really have to think
about is all those declarations Trump
made about health care like the infamous
Lesley Stahl 60 minutes interview when
he talked about all the things he was
going to do he might have been talking
about life insurance the entire time
like he all of those comments might
never have been about health insurance
they might always have been about life
insurance I guess at this point we don't
really know